osteoarthritis of the thumb also known
as basal joint arthritis is a problem
with the joint at the base of your thumb
cartilage covering the bones in your
joint has worn away
causing pain and other symptoms
there is no cure for osteoarthritis and
it usually gets worse over time
but treatments that don't require
surgery can help relieve symptoms in the
early stages for example you can put ice
on the joint several times a day
pinching with your thumb may increase
the stress on the joint and result in
more pain
to help reduce your pain your healthcare
provider may give you tips on how to
change the way you pinch or grasp
objects
you may also be advised to wear a splint
to limit movement
this allows the joint some time to rest
and heal
medicines such as acetaminophen can help
reduce pain
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
such as ibuprofen or aspirin can help
reduce both pain and swelling
you may also receive a steroid injection
directly into your joint to reduce the
swelling and provide pain relief
if you have questions about
osteoarthritis of the thumb or which
treatment option may be best for you
talk to your health care provider
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you